you got another number for us I have
yeah yeah it's the aim but I'll just
write it down shot like that's probably
the best thing to do so it is 10 to the
10 to the 10 to the 10 to the 10 and
then this is the strange bit to the one
point one okay this has been claimed to
be the largest finite time that has ever
been calculated by a physicist in there
in a published paper this is the paper
it's a bit of a weird paper not had a
huge impact I mean I think it's about
black hole information loss and
conscious beings we went we won't go
down that route he actually calculates
something called the air Poincare
recurrence time for a certain type of
universe within a certain cosmological
model and this is the the number that he
gets out
this is the one I'm on about let me just
check a lot the number of tens right
yeah I did okay hey it's equation
sixteen so you put Planck times
millennia or whatever because basically
it don't really make any difference
whether you use seconds plant tines but
then year years when the number is this
big but there's other interesting
observe here which is this one here you
know you've got three tens to the 2.08
that's the Poincare recurrence time fit
for our universe
what's all this a perdu okay so one
career occurrence time this is this is
something that's arisen from statistical
mechanics very simply you know we if we
had a pack of cards and we you know we
only got finite number of cards in that
pack and let's say we keep dealing each
other you know hands of five cards
eventually if we do it for long enough
you know you're going to get a Royal
Flush Brady that's guaranteed to happen
and then if you wait long enough again
you'll get another one and so on and so
on and that's true because there's a
finite number of cards now what juan
curi realized is if you take a gas of
particles you can put a gas in a box and
you can put all the particles in one
corner of the box and then they'll
disperse and then they'll move around
and but what prank rerecords tells is
that after a very very very very long
time those particles will eventually
return to the corner of the box
you always get a repetition and it's
basically because the thing that
controls the evolution of that system
only has a finite region of what we call
phase space of sort of solution space
that's accessible to it and so
eventually you always come back to it
arbitrary close to where you started the
timescales a truly enormous before you
start expecting it to happen you can
apply this quantum mechanically as well
so when you're doing it in quantum
mechanics what you're really talking
about is sort of the evolution of
microstates within the quantum sense so
you know this sort of building making a
quantum building blocks of your system
and they will eventually return they
will evolve but eventually return to
their initial state and what Dom page
and this paper has tried to do is he's
actually applied that to various types
of universe models of various types of
universe it's a bit of a cheat because a
universe is what we call a macroscopic
objects a large object it's not really a
my quantum microstate in some sense it
what it is is it's an ensemble and
average of all the microstates so what
he's tried to do is he's tried to say
okay I'm going to treat the universe as
this is this average of all these states
but then I'm going to count up all the
possible averages and treat them as it
as a sort of microstate in itself so
it's a bit of a cheat it gets an extra
exponential AB from that are we talking
about
Jupiter's over there the energy other
galaxies over there I'm in this room
feel now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
that okay now it's a very very large
number of possibilities that you can
have but it's finite and so as the
system evolves it's only got it and it
can only evolve the system can only
evolve through a finite number of
possibilities and eventually it involves
back to very started so actually it's in
I've often heard it said that the
universe for example will then you know
will evolve will expand eventually
everything will be very far to spread
out very far because the expansion of
the universe that all objects will have
collapsed the forms black holes that
then those black holes will have
evaporated from Hawking radiation or you
will have is this very sort of you know
sort of bleak landscape of them of just
radiation and has come out of these
evaporate black holes that's uniformly
distributed and it be very boring okay
but that isn't the end state of the
universe the end state of the universe
is this is that after these truly epic
timescales
you will eventually have a point career
occurrence and you'll get back your
windup back where you started from and
it's quite easy to see how it might
happen
imagine you have this sort of bleak
universe right just have a little
fluctuation that little fluctuation sort
of you know gathers together builds up
other things eventually it sort of forms
a sort of galaxy even you know from that
galaxy you get planet stars and you keep
go and you keep going eventually you'll
get back to a situation where it looks
like it is today now what I think is is
fair I think it's a fair point is that
there's no way of ever being aware of
these repetitions over these large times
and the reason is you can never build a
device you could never be an observer
that could measure this
the and the right and that's that that's
because over these huge timescales such
a device or such an observer wouldn't
definitely thermalize would definitely
become part of this recurrence itself
and so there's never anybody or anything
that could measure it there's this sort
of idea you know this sort of notion
within physics is that if you can't
measure it it's irrelevant in some sense
so but according to this in this in this
number of in this time in this number of
years you and I are going to make this
video again you and I are going to make
this video again I know this is the app
that's less than that this is for a
special type of universe that's
particularly large okay
the number forever for us is at least
less than this other number that he's
written down here which is 10 to the 10
to the 10 to the 10 to the 2 point 0 8
as so I'll just say years okay so this
one is the one that applies to us in
this unit in our visible universe arc
what we call our causal patch this one
applies to a C and what is the Poincare
recurrence time for a truly vast domain
of universe that you can get in models
of cosmology so they all they're all
based of course on the same idea we can
work through where this where these
numbers come from
so the Poincare recurrence times of any
system is roughly proportional to the to
the number of sort of states in that
system because we're applying this to
the universe this is really the number
of macro states the number of these
averages of microstates that you can
talk about so let's call this n macro
this then we would expect it to be about
the exponential of the number of
microstates now why is that well this
doesn't really have to be an A this
could be a to whatever basically any
microstate is either in or out of the
averaging with some weighting and so
this is the number that you get out the
number of microstates when you related
the entropy is e to the entropy let's
let's look at some volume of the
universe
ok of some radius R then the entropy
we've done this before and it's to say
oh I guess you have before the entropy
that you could possibly have in this
this region of space basically it's
proportional to I'll just be
bit sloppy with factors are squared over
the Planck length squared so the next
step is e to the e to the so now let's
apply so let's apply it to the really
big number that he does okay so the
question is what's our well the radius
of the universe is about 10 to the 26
meters yeah our visible universe okay so
as far as we can see what we call our
causal patch the Planck length is about
10 to the minus 34 meters so R over m el
Planck squared is about 10 to the 120
which is a number you often see in a in
physics actually it's sort of the number
that's associated with the cosmological
constant problems but anyway
well 120 is about 10 to the 2.08 that's
where that is coming from there are why
so precise about this 2.08 because what
he's going to do next is so the number
we have is e to the e to the 10 to the
10 to the 2.08
but what he does here is he just
approximates use these ease as tens
which is fine really and the broader
scheme is saying e 10 for the sake of
cosmology they're more or less the same
thing all these become tens and you get
10 - 10 - 10 to the 2.8 which hopefully
is what he's got there and it is ok so
that's where that number comes from so
so this is basically the Poincare
recurrence time for our visible universe
that our patch Y is the other number
bigger well because the other number is
is is a days look in it he's trying to
get a big number is like if I get to
these tribes get to thinking of what
he's looking at there is is a model of
inflation now inflation is some time
model of the very early universe where
the universe grew really quickly at the
very small patch of universe the amount
by which it blows up depends on various
parameters in the model but basically
the thing that you get is you get to the
size of the universe so our for that
case is of order e to the 4 PI over m
squared ok so this is actually R over L
Planck
you've done everything complying units
so that 4m here is the mass of some of
this in fluent what we call the
influence on field it's just some field
in the model that causes the expansion 1
over M Squared is 10 to the 12 I think
it might be 13 actually 10 to the 12 so
this is about 10 to the 13 right over
all because their team is about 10 okay
bear with me so this is e to the 10 to
the third team roughly the 13 well is
about 10 to the 1.1 that's where the 1.1
comes from he's very precise about this
one point why don't ya is very sloppy
with some of the other faculties get e
to the e to another e to the 10 to the
10 to the 1.1 and then we do the same
thing we turn all these into tens help
me understand because you know I have
big numbers there how long time is this
okay so this this is true divas like I
said there's no device there's no
observer that anything that could
survive this kind of like the time scale
in fact you will probably say that the
universe is more likely to tunnel out of
the current state before this could
happen in some sense this is such a long
time scale that one might say that see
the probability of tunneling to a new
phase of the universe completely
different is actually going to dominate
over this that would occur first so
maybe this is a kind of a relevant point
but yeah I mean it's truly fast I mean
it's bigger than aim than a googol
clearly way bigger is it bigger than a
googolplex I think so so you know let's
just check that so good year clearly it
is it's enormous
it's pretty obvious biggest grains
number but you know grains numbers the
daddy right sir well I didn't actually
know about this paper but oh yeah I just
I was there I just thought up big
numbers let's see what's interesting
about big numbers and and then I
stumbled across this paper it's the lot
what he claims but he says it he claims
it's the so far as I know these are the
longest finite times that have been
explicitly calculated by any physicist
so where this somebody is calculated a
longer one and I'm sure some of the
viewers will try to calculate Oh God
then claimed that they were but this is
in a published paper I see gotta get the
paper published but and the challenge is
on I guess it's a find a long one it's
probably the probably has been SIDS but
he was the one that pointed it out
you